[Música]
bueno cuando a uno le llaman para dar
una charla una charla ted se activan
todos los restos del cerebro todos
tienes una charla
innovadora emocionante que nunca antes
hayas contado tiene que ser una charla
que deja un mensaje claro que llegue al
público que haga que se levanten
para empezar tengo que deciros que solo
puedo defraudar os
el listón está muy alto y es muy difícil
llegar llegar hasta ahí porque al fin y
al cabo no soy más que un tipo normal
seguramente como todos los que estáis
aquí
pero contamos una historia que es un
tanto difícil y un tanto complicada de
armar porque no bien hablamos de lo de
lo habitual de lo que me tocaría de cómo
hemos creado pocoyó de cómo hemos hecho
a la familia telerín me voy a contaros
cómo tener razón
no sirve de nada
o puede no servir de nada si se utiliza
tan mal como yo la utilice para contaros
cómo teniendo razón fui capaz de
cargarme una compañía
de ganarme un montón de puestos de
trabajo de fastidiar la relación con
algunos amigos y dar
pero
[Música]
empecemos por donde se debe por el
principio mirad a finales de los 90
trabajamos en una de estas consultoras
de internet estas que al principio
tienes que con un traje impecable y
luego nos dijeron que los trajes no que
ya estaban mal vistos teníamos clientes
enormes que nos pagaban muy bien
teníamos un proyecto interesante pero no
nos llenaba no era lo que queríamos
hacer así que decidimos abandonarlo
decidimos empezar de cero
decidimos que en el momento de abordar
de hacer aquello que nos apetecía
aquello que nos gustaba que nos motiva
sé
bueno
[Música]
queríamos ser nuestros propios jefes
nuestro racionamiento era muy naif era
muy de niño pequeño
no queríamos tener jefes queríamos
hacerlo solos queremos hacer lo que nos
gustaba y que nos gustaba los
videojuegos
la tele en el cine me gustaban los
cómics
me gustaban los dibujos animados
porque si os pregunto seguramente todos
tendréis unos dibujos animados de
vuestra infancia que de alguna manera os
marcaron que de alguna manera dijeron
esto es
mi dibujo animado favorito este es el
mío
mazinger z era la piedra la pera los
dados por la tarde no me podía perder
más en el zeta como sabéis no se puede
robar no había hs
dentro de todo ese mundo que estábamos
construyendo de ese afán por ser
nuestros jefes de desarrollar aquello
que nos apetecía
estamos en la edad en que empezábamos a
tener hijos era muy pequeño estaban a
punto de nacer y pensamos bueno por qué
no fabricar los recuerdos de nuestros
hijos por qué no regalarles un contenido
por qué no regalarles una serie
y bueno pues así nació
este niño
este poco yo que no nos dio pocos
quebraderos de cabeza
una cosa que aprendimos es el trabajo
principal que tiene alguien que
que tiene una empresa alguien que
trabaja en un proyecto de estas
características es que tiene que
aprender a resolver problemas nos
pasamos todo el día resolviendo
problemas todo el día es nuestra función
principal resolver problemas el primero
que nos enfrentamos es nunca habíamos
producido una serie no sabíamos producir
televisión nunca lo habíamos hecho
tenemos un diseño preciosa hemos logrado
un diseño magnífico
pero tenemos un problema y es que no
sabíamos ponerle fondos
no éramos capaces de poner pocoyó con un
fondo sen bastaba no funcionaba había
mucho ruido en pantalla y encima ponerle
fondos era más caro
así que sin que se entere ningún
periodista lo que hicimos fue hacerles
con los fondos blancos
podría contarnos que fue fruto de un
análisis sesudo el diseño blanco puro la
limpieza mentira
no sabíamos producir con fondos y encima
era más caro así que decidimos hacerlo
con fondos blancos la verdad que en
cuanto a por qué yo
la respuesta de la gente fue excelente
a los niños les encantaba a los padres
les encantaba les encantaba la música
les encantaba en inglés la voz de
station fried en español la de josé
maría del río quiero decir nos dio
muchas alegrías muchas alegrías la
verdad y sobre todo estar agradecido
tanto es así
fue portada de wall street journal
este pato no creáis que también nos dio
un montón de quebraderos de cabeza nos
dio un montón de problemas pato no era
pato era de aquí
queremos hacer una serie muy
internacional tenía que hablar en inglés
por supuesto no tenía sentido que
tuviese otro nombre
el caso es que nuestra asesora educativa
una británica excelente con un
conocimiento enorme de la pedagogía y de
la necesidad y de la forma en que los
niños aprenden nos dijo que no podía
llamarse de aquí porque esto no era un
pato
entonces que no podía llamarse de aquí
tenemos que buscar otro nombre no podía
llamarse de aquí se empeñó imagínense
gastado un dineral en hacer el registro
de marca teníamos los domingos pero no
puede llamarse de aquí así que una de
las muchas reuniones de lalín storming
buscando una solución a ese problema
alguien medio en broma se le ocurrió
decir y por qué no pato
nos vamos a broma al principio hasta que
alguien dijo esas tres palabras que son
capaces de cambiar la historia de
españa' no hay huevos
[Aplausos]
ya tenemos nombre así si pato what i
hate you out of my soul
es maravilloso me encanta suena
fenomenal perfecto pato
a los cinco meses vino a cenar a madrid
ya los guiones obviamente estaba ya
grabando voces por cierto que significa
pato
de aquí
le encantó me encantó que se divirtió
mucho esa noche será por el vino
pero no vengo hablaros
sólo esto este fue el punto de partida
la verdad que hacia asia a finales de
2007 principio 2008
salimos de la compañía dejamos zinkia
bueno consideraron que yo no hacía falta
pues esa capacidad creativa ese talento
que se requería en otro tipo de cosas y
bueno nos poníamos de acuerdo decidimos
irnos otro problema imaginaos la congoja
dejas a tu hijo es como un desgarro
duele duele
la respuesta fue nos pusimos a trabajar
en dos meses teníamos una compañía nueva
en seis meses teníamos una propiedad
nueva antes de final de año la habíamos
financiado y estamos empezando la
producción el resultado bueno excelente
éramos felices habíamos conseguido
reinventarnos habíamos sacado adelante
un proyecto nuevo bailábamos la conga
nos lo pasábamos realmente bien las
ideas fluían hicimos en dos años lo que
no habíamos hecho nunca desarrollamos
tres conceptos tres proyectos nuevos de
verdad no cabíamos en nosotros de gozo
teníamos nuestra compañía otra vez
estábamos en el mercado
pero en 2012 algo cambió
algo se torció esa crisis que había
venido ya desde finales 2007
contagiando todo nos llegó no llegó la
crisis cuando arrancaba la segunda
temporada de la serie uno de nuestros
coproductor es un canal público nos dijo
que bueno le habían recortado los
presupuestos y no podía seguir
invirtiendo no solo eso no podía seguir
emitiendo la serie
cosas de amortizaciones y cosas de que
la gente que habla en excel seguramente
entenderá a mí me costaba
si la televisión no podía emitir el
juguetero no podía pagar sus mínimos
garantizados y no podían del juguete y
si el juguetero no podían del juguete
los licenciatarios no podían vender cada
uno sus productos los libros
es decir se halla en producción de
circunstancias en cadena que estaban
empezando a expresar la compañía en
paralelo el otro productor portugués con
la troika en su país le retiraron los
fondos a través de lo que invertía y nos
quedamos sin dinero de la noche a la
mañana
en tres meses teníamos menos dos
millones y medio de horas en la caja no
éramos capaces de hacer frente a los
pagos de los salarios a los pagos de los
proveedores estábamos absolutamente
asfixiados
esto no podía ser teníamos contratos
firmados teníamos cosas hechas teníamos
la razón de nuestro lado tenía razón
cogí la razón y me la puse por montera
y con la razón me fui a visitar a cada
uno de nuestros socios y dije amigos no
podéis hacernos esto fijaos lo que
tenemos detrás tengo razón
me decían si tiene razón pero no podemos
hacer nada son las circunstancias así
que yo me iba con mi razón y a veces la
dejaba en el aparador de mi casa y la
miraba ya ver si tengo razón
de corazón esto no puede ser arreglar
solo seguro si tengo razón
jugaba con la razón o al fútbol con la
razón
tiene razón las cosas se tienen que
arreglar la razón empezó a crecer entre
mis manos empezó a crecer a crecer a
crecer era como un tumor
la razón tener razón empezó a contagiar
me empezó a llenarme a llenarme de ira
tenía razón me la daban pero no hacíamos
nada no estábamos solucionando el
problema tenía toda esa gente y detrás
no podíamos parar que iba a hacer la
razón seguía creciendo y yo con ella
y me enfado y me enfado
cogí la razón
y la utilice como un arma arrojadiza
empecé a pelearme porque tenía razón no
estaba buscando resolver los problemas
como en esos fondos blancos
en el nombre de pato lo que estaba
haciendo era atizar con la razón estaba
golpeando con la razón estaba tratando
de convencer al mundo a golpes de que yo
tenía razón y que tenían que hacerme
caso y cumplir lo que se habían
comprometido
fue un error eso nos condujo a perder la
compañía perdimos amigos perdimos con
productores no conseguí nada
no conseguí
la razón solo me sirvió para destruir lo
que habíamos construido en un montón de
tiempo porque la razón por sí sola no
sirve de nada
si no tenemos las herramientas adecuadas
si no lo utilizamos con criterio si no
somos capaces si no somos capaces de
usar la razón como un medio para
resolver los problemas no sirve de nada
de nada y me costó mucho tiempo
entenderlo cuando me di cuenta teníamos
eso un erial
un erial
mirad la razón bien utilizada es un arma
poderosa pero entre tener razón y
resolver un problema he aprendido que es
mucho mejor resolver un problema y es lo
que procuro ha sido mi aprendizaje
después de cinco años y de meterme en
este lío y quizá como la vida no deja de
arte oportunidades al cabo de diez años
me vuelto a encontrar con este niño azul
y ahora lo único que quiero a lo único
que aspiro es a dedicarme a resolver
problemas y no a tener razón
[Aplausos]